kill every Targaryen
everyone who wasn't
is an enemy
so I did it bring me his head we take
what is ours
[Music]
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones video I
want to start things off by saying I'm
not exactly sure what to call this but
you need to know right up front that
this isn't really a prediction or Theory
video I guess I just wanted to talk
about something that I would like to see
although I doubt it ever happens what I
want to talk about is what it would be
like to view things through the eyes of
the night king whenever we are watching
the show or reading the books everything
takes place through the eyes of one of
the characters but I think it would be
really interesting if we were able to
see some things through the eyes of the
night king or even one of his White
Walkers
I was recently watching an episode of
Game of Thrones and I was watching the
scene where the white Walker takes crest
her son to the lanes have always went
there for the night King to turn into a
white Walker during this scene we
actually get a few quick glimpses
through the eyes of the white Walker and
the night king as they are holding the
baby as I was watching this I started to
think about other possibilities that I
think could make things a little more
intriguing I think it's safe to say that
most of us are wanting to learn more
about the White Walkers and the night
King they were pretty much the very
first thing we were introduced to in the
books in the show yet we know very
little about them so far all we really
know is the White Walkers are thousands
of years old from the time preceding the
Age of Heroes that were created to
protect the children of the forest from
the first men who had waged war on them
ever since they arrived from Essos
however the White Walkers eventually
broke free of the children's control and
became the most feared creatures in
Westeros posing a threat to everything
living 8,000 years before Robert's
rebellion the longest winter in history
fell on the entire world and lasted a
whole generation and the darkness and
cold of the long night the White Walkers
descended upon Westeros from the far
north killing everything in their path
and reanimating the dead as White's to
serve as their foot soldiers eventually
the people of Westeros rallied against
them in a conflict known as the war for
the
dawn they were able to beat the white
walkers and drive them back into the
lanes of always winter then with help
from Giants and the children of the
forest the wall was raised to prevent
their return the Nights Watch was
founded to guard the wall in the realms
of men should the mysterious threat ever
rise again the white walkers remained a
legend for thousands of years but now
they have returned and we don't know why
we do know the night king and his white
walkers are very powerful their arrival
is usually accompanied by blizzards and
the dropping of temperatures they can
also freeze just about anything they
touch one of the white walkers was able
to free Sam sword to the point that it's
shattered white walkers also have
superhuman strength as one managed to
toss Amaral Tarly several feet away
after he bit slapped him the white
walkers also carry swords and spears
that are made from magical ice crystals
however one of their most deadly
abilities is to reanimate the dead as
their servants known as whites they are
actually capable of reviving any dead
animal as whites as a few white walkers
have been seen riding undead horses and
even recently we have seen undead polar
bears and now array animated dragon I
also believe they have other powers that
have yet to be fully revealed and this
is mostly based on how the night King
was created we finally saw the creation
of the night King but this still left so
many things unanswered the children of
the forest captured a man and tied him
to a weirwood tree then they shove
dragon glass into his heart which turned
him into the first white Walker who is
now known as the night King the only
problem is we don't know who this man is
nor do we even know for a fact if he is
still the same night king that we see
today the actor that was tied up to the
tree as the same actor who plays the
night king however there was that
painting in the cable and Dragonstone
that showed the night king with a beard
so this certainly muddies the water a
little bit now that the night King is
active again we need to find out what is
motivating him is he still seeking out
to eliminate mankind since that was his
goal when he was created or does he have
motives of his own while the White
Walkers and their rapidly growing army
of zombies have all been a part of a
major plot on Game of Thrones since the
series began we're now seven seasons in
and we still haven't gotten much of an
explanation as to why the night king is
waging a war against the people of
Westeros his reason for killing every
living thing in his path could be the
same as Circe's maybe he just wants to
have as much power as he can possibly
obtain but he could also be doing all of
this for an entirely different reason
that the show hasn't explored yet which
is what I'm hoping happens as of right
now if we're gonna learn more about the
night King this information will most
likely come through Sam and bran we know
Sam was trying to find answers about the
night King and before he left the
Citadel he stole several old books from
the library
and I would bet they'd have some
information about the others we also
know bran stark and look into the past
and see pretty much any event in history
thanks to brand we were able to see how
the night King was created
now that brain and Sam have teamed up
they will most likely combine their
skills to find some more answers about
how to stop the night king from wiping
out the entire realm lately I have been
thinking what if we could get some of
this exposition from the night king
himself i fully believe this would be a
new fascinating layer they could add in
the final season or at least add in one
episode I know people have always
wondered if the White Walkers have some
kind of a culture we know that they are
organized to a certain extent but how
organized are they do they have their
own Smith who creates all their weapons
and armor do they plan out their attacks
by placing chess pieces on a large map
who takes care of all the white Walker
babies or do they immediately grow up
into adults after they are turned by the
knight Kings touch these are some of the
things we will never know unless we can
get a glimpse into their day-to-day
activities and this leads me to some of
the thoughts I've been having about
seeing things from the knight Kings
point of view now I personally believe
the man who was turned into the knight
King was a stark not only was he a stark
but he was also a green seer and a warg
just like bran stark this might be one
of the reasons why the children decided
to turn this man into their magical ice
weapon the children may have used him
because he was a powerful war and they
needed someone that could control an
entire army because the children were
outnumbered I have always thought that's
why their eyes turned blue just like his
but what makes him an even bigger threat
is the possibility of him being a green
seer if he wasn't a green seer before
the children caught him then they
probably made him
greenseer when they use their magic to
turn him into the night king since he
was created by the children of the
forest it makes sense to me that he
would be tapping into the same power
source as of them and bran which is most
likely the cause of the night king being
able to interact with bran inside of the
weirwood net ever since I saw the night
King reached out and grabbed bran inside
of a vision I have been sold on the idea
that the night king is also a green seer
and he uses the weirwood tree system
just like bran does but I think he's
even more powerful than brand because
he's had thousands of years to Train
thanks to all the brands dreams and
visions we have had many things
explained to us this way we first saw
the three-eyed Raven in one of brains
dreams we were introduced to judge and
read in one of brains dreams and we have
seen all kinds of things when brain taps
into the weirwood net most notably we
saw the birth of Jon Snow which
confirmed his parents were Liana and
Rhaegar making John the Song of Ice and
Fire now just imagine if we were able to
see some of the things the night King
sees when he goes into the weirwood net
he has been using this somehow because
he was able to set a trap for bran which
allowed him to gain access into the
three-eyed Ravens cave to kill him now
what if the night King has been getting
visions - what if this was how the night
king knew when to become active again
and prepare to head south all of us have
been wondering what caused the night
king to start attacking again did he see
something in a vision that motivated him
to organize all of his soldiers some
people think it was the birth of the
Dragons other people think it was the
birth of Daenerys Targaryen or the birth
of Jon Snow the night king must have
been made aware of a major event that
motivated him enough to start forming a
massive army now imagine if season 8
begins with a cold open and we see the
night Kings entire army kind of like a
season 7 started when we saw the Night
king's army moving south but this time
we could see things through the eyes of
the night king instead of having the
camera in front of him I think it would
be amazing if the episode began and we
were inside the night King's head and
looking through his eyes we could then
see the night King walk up to a weirwood
tree that is in the north and he can
place his hand on the weirwood tree
begin to download visions just like bran
does but now we would finally see what
the night king wants imagine if he
places his hand on the tree and we see
his entire life flashed before his eyes
if the night King is a stark the visions
could begin within being at Winterfell
or someplace in the north and we could
see what happens that caused the
children to pick him does he come from a
special bloodline was he already a green
seer and that's why the children
captured him because he already had some
power in him we can learn so much this
way and it would be even more
interesting than just getting this
information from Brian or Sam after we
see visions of the night king as a man
then we could get visions of what made
him break free from the children of the
forest the children created him to be
their weapon but something happened that
caused them to lose control now imagine
if we could see what that was - the
night Kings visions then we could even
find out how Chrysler was able to make a
deal with him
did Craster find out a way to
communicate what the night king is
Christ or related to the night king in
some way since this is the last season
we need answers to some of these
long-standing mysteries surrounding the
night king after we get filled in with
some more of his backstory then we could
see him start to get visions of what is
causing him to move south at this point
in time did the night King know Rhaegar
and Lyanna were gonna eventually get
together and create a baby made up of
ice and fire did the night King know
Daenerys was going to be born and she
would eventually hatch dragon eggs maybe
it's all connected to bran is the night
king receiving visions of where bran is
at all times
perhaps we could see the night King get
a vision and he sees brand sitting in
his wheelchair at the heart tree in
Winterfell then we would know that's
what he's after if bran isn't his main
target then maybe it has something to do
with John and Danny's baby
we know the night king uses babies as
sacrifices so maybe John and Daenerys
are no good to him because they are
already grown into adults all this time
people thought it was the birth of the
Narus or the birth of John that caused
the night Kings powers to awaken but
what if it is actually their child he is
after John and Daenerys are special
characters in their own right but when
you combine those two it could create a
super baby that the night King really
wants to get his hands on now I know the
night King was active before John and
Daenerys were born
but he could have received a vision over
fifty years ago which motivated him
enough to slowly start building his army
again until the right time it would be
really interesting if we could view some
of the story through his eyes because I
would love to see what he is seeing when
he goes into the weirwood net the night
King may have seen visions of John and
Daenerys hooking up on the boat and he
could be getting visions now that is
telling him John and Daenerys are
heading to Winterfell
there are honestly so many different
possibilities that I would love to
explore we are always seeing things
through the eyes of the good guys but I
would like to get a different
perspective on all of the events taking
place I doubt they will ever do a scene
with the night king like this but I just
thought it would be a cool way to give
us some of the answers to the questions
we have all been wondering about let me
know what you think about them doing
something like this would you like to
take a peek inside the night Kings head
or are you fine with the way things have
been going either way I want to thank
you all for stopping by and watching
today's video I really appreciate that I
also want to thank everyone on patreon
for continuing to support this channel I
hope you all have a great day
I will see you again very soon bye
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]